we're joined now by Dame Donna Kinnear
the chief executive of the Royal College
of Nursing thank you very much for being
on the program today and so what do the
frontline nurses and doctors need to
deal with coronavirus and are they
getting it so nurses need two things
they need to be tested so for the virus
so that they can know whether they need
to take time off work or whether they
can continue to work and they also need
proper protective personal protective
equipment to be able to do their job
well and so just to take those two
things in turn and firstly with the
testing the government's saying that
it's gonna be rolling out testing or
trying to ramp it up for the frontline
staff many people will be wondering why
on earth this hasn't happened sooner
what's your take on that and I believe
it should have happened sooner but we
are where we are and we need it now so
nurses are everyday they carry out
services to patients or care and
treatment to patients and they will be
less than one meter away so they
particularly need to know whether the
person that they're dealing with whether
they themselves have been infected with
kovat 19 so that they can take time the
appropriate time off but also protect
themselves and their families I'm gonna
know it's hard to put figures on these
kind of things when things are so busy
but do you have any idea about the
proportion of nurses or NHS workers more
widely who are having to take time off
having to self isolate because of
symptoms so last week it was about 20%
of nurses or frontline workers that
we're doing it I don't know the exact
proportion of nurses in that 20 to 25
percent so there are a number of nurses
that would like to be tested to get on
with their job if they are not positive
the köppen 19 that does feel like a
really large amount at a time when the
health service is clearly under pressure
as well and the other thing that you
said that frontline workers really need
from the government is the personal
protective equipment so that's things
like masks gloves goggles is that
equipment getting through to the
frontline well we are working on it at
this moment and I'm personally working
very hard
to ensure that nurses get these the
equipment at the front line but I think
that it is down to sometimes out the
Trust's that they're working for to free
up that equipment so nurses can utilize
it and work and protect both themselves
and the patients that they are serving
and I'm hearing from the nurses on the
front line that they're being denied
access to masks and aprons and this has
to stop because it's that is the nurse
that does that assist assessment of the
kit of who she's providing care to and
it's fine in hospitals but we also need
it for out of hospital care because
these nurses are going into homes or
working as in in outreach facilities to
undifferentiated patients patients but
we don't know if they've got the virus
or not and therefore the healthcare
worker or nurse has to be adequately
protected do you think that NASA this
could be redeployed to different parts
of the country and to deal with and the
outbreaks that are happening quite
specific locations we've obviously seen
a large number of cases in places like
London and the West Midlands so I think
there are some moves to do that we are
we are estimating that a lot of nurses
will be needed to deliver critical care
and we know that we've just opened we're
just about to open up Excel with extra
beds so I am expecting nurses to be do
be deployed I guess what I would say is
that actually you we need those nurses
to willingly volunteer to do this as
opposed to being forced to go from one
part of the country to another and
actually we do need nurses who already
working tirelessly to step up if they've
got those skills and offer them to the
services that require them at this
moment in time and just finally we've of
course seen the really worrying and
figures from death rates infection rates
over the last few days ratcheting up do
you think the NHS has got the capacity
to cope with what we're likely to see in
the weeks ahead well much depends on if
the if we all obey or listen to the
advice that we've been given it gives
the NHS a fighting chance to save lives
if people do remain indoors and are not
spreading the virus so that actually the
NHS can cope with the patients that has
already got
so I think it's really important for us
to listen to that advice to wash our
hands to stay indoors to do the things
that we need to do to help the NHS to be
able to save lives
okay Dame Donna can air thank you very
much for being on the program today